- I don't want to be single, okay?
I just want to be married again.
(audience laughing)
- This is Rachel, another
Lincoln High survivor.
This everybody, this is
Chandler and Phoebe, and Joey.
And you remember my brother Ross?
- Sure.
- Hey.
- Hi.
(Rachel shrieks)
(audience laughing)
- You know, you probably didn't know this,
but back in high school, I had a
major crush on you.
- I knew.
- You did, oh.
I always figured you just thought
I was Monica's geeky older brother.
- I did.
- Oh.
(audience laughing)
Listen, do you think,
and try not to let my
intense vulnerability
become any kind of a factor here,
(audience laughing)
but do you think it would be okay
if I asked you out sometime maybe?
- Yeah.
Maybe.
- Okay.
- Yes!
Did you see that?
- You were incredible.
- Did you see that?
- A brand new woman,
ladies and gentle.
- Ross, thank you,
thank you, I could not
have done this without you.
(audience laughing)
- Okay,
more clothes in the
dryer? (audience laughing)
Oh!
(Rachel shrieks)
(audience laughing)
- I'm fine, I'm fine.
See, I see big passion in your future.
- Really?
- I do.
- Oh, Ross,
you're so great.
(audience laughing)
Everybody, this is Paolo.
(Ross moaning)
(audience laughing)
- Wasn't it supposed to be just a fling?
Huh?
Shouldn't it be
flung by now?
- What are you still doing here?
She just broke up with the guy,
it's time for you to swoop in.
- I'm so sick of guys.
(audience laughing)
I don't wanna look
at another guy, I don't wanna
think about another guy,
I don't even wanna be near another guy.
(audience laughing)
- What happened to forget relationships?
I'm done with men?
The whole penis embargo.
(audience laughing)
- Oh, I don't know,
I guess it's not about no guys,
it's about the right guy, you know?
- Forget about her.
- He's right, man, please move on.
Go to China, eat Chinese food.
- Of course there they just call it food.
- [Rachel] Oh my god.
- I can't believe he did this.
- Oh come on, Ross?
Remember back in college when
he fell in love with Carol
and bought her that ridiculously
expensive cristal duck?
- What did you just say?
Oh my god.
- Everyone, this is Julie.
- Julie.
- You gotta tell Ross how you feel.
- Oh come on, how can I just tell him?
What about Julie?
- What about her?
They've only been going out for two weeks.
Ross has been in love with
you for like 10 years.
- I am over you.
And that, my friend, is
what they call closure.
Oh my god, Ross, no hang up the phone.
Give me the phone, Ross give me the phone,
give me the phone, give me the phone.
(audience laughing)
- You're over me?
You had no right to tell me
you ever had feelings for me.
- What?
- I was doing great with Julie
before I found out about you.
(rock music playing)
(rain falling)
Come on, you gotta give me another chance.
- No.
- Rach, come on, look I know how you must-
- No, you don't, Ross.
Imagine the worst things
you think about yourself,
now how would you feel if the one person
that you trusted the most in the world
not only thinks them too,
but actually uses them as the
reasons not to be with you.
- Okay, dad.
- Rachel, ready or not,
here comes your knight in shining, oh no.
- [Monica] Bye, don't wait up!
- [Rachel] Chip!
- [Judy] Oh dear.
Jack how do I turn this off?
(audience cheering)
- See?
He's her lobster.
- Listen, I'm sorry I had to work tonight.
- Oh that's okay.
You were worth the wait.
And I don't just mean tonight.
- 'Cause I love you.
- Oh yeah?
- Yeah!
- Well, I love you too.
- Well that's the first
time we've said that.
- Yes it is.
- Well I'm gonna kiss you.
- Well, you better.
(audience laughing)
Oh I'm sorry we're closed...
Hey sailor.
Ross do you realize this is
the first time in my life
I'm doing something I actually care about?
This is the first time in my life
I'm doing something I'm actually good at.
I mean if you don't get that-
- No hey I get that.
Okay, I get that big time
and I'm happy for you,
but I'm tired of having a relationship
with your answering machine, okay?
I don't know what to do anymore.
- Well neither do I.
Maybe we should just take a break.
- Okay, okay, fine you're right.
Let's take a break, let's cool off, okay?
Let's get some frozen yogurt or something.
- No.
(sighs) A break from us.
- Do I know why we're rushing?
- Yeah, you know the girlfriend
I told you about last night?
Well it turns out that she
wants to get back together
with me, oh I found it!
(audience laughing)
- That's so great for you guys!
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Good luck with your girlfriend.
- Thank you. (winces)
This morning you said
there was nothing so big
that we couldn't work passed it together.
- No, what the hell did I know?
- Look, there's got to be a
way we can work passed this,
okay?
I can't imagine my life without you.
You know, without
without these arms.
And your face and heart.
Your good heart, Rach.
(Rachel crying)
- No.
- She's moving on, okay?
If it's not this guy, it's
gonna be somebody else.
And unless you're thinking
about subletting my peephole,
you are gonna have to get used to the fact
that the relationship is over.
- I knew you needed someone
to be with you tonight.
Come on.
- I cannot believe you.
- What?
- That is the sweetest thing.
- Would it be okay with you
if set Ross up on a date?
- Oh.
With who?
(Bonnie breathing heavy)
- Hi Bonnie.
- Hi.
- You know, hey, you're the
one who ended it, remember?
- Yeah because I was mad at you,
not because I stopped loving you.
If time was what you needed
just to gain a little perspective.
(audience laughing)
- We were on a break.
- I thought we'd gotten to a place
where we could be happy for each other.
I mean, was that just me?
- All right, I'll do it.
- Oh thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
(audience laughing)
- Emily.
- Yes.
- I'm Rachel Green.
- Thank goodness.
- He's with Emily at a bed
and breakfast in Vermont.
- What, oh my god.
- Emily and I, we decided to
to get married.
I was just telling the guys.
- Yeah, I heard.
I have sexual feelings for him,
but I do love him. (gasps)
(audience laughing)
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm going to London.
(audience wooing)
- What?
What do you mean you're going to London?
- Yeah I have to tell
Ross that I love him.
I just needed to tell you,
congratulations.
- I Ross,
- Take thee Emily,
- Take thee Rachel.
Look, this marriage is never gonna work
if you don't trust me.
- You're right.
- So,
can you trust me?
- No.
(Rachel laughing)
(audience gasping)
- Hello Mrs. Ross.
- Hello Mr. Rachel.
(audience laughing)
(gasping) Who got married?
- You did.
(audience laughing)
- What?
Wait hello, we didn't get married.
- We didn't get married,
that's ridiculous
(both gasping)
I cannot believe you didn't tell me
we are still married.
- Look I was going to tell you.
- When?
After the birth of our first secret child?
- If you don't wanna be together,
you'll have to file for divorce.
- That's great?
You happy now?
Look what you did with
your funny, funny form.
- Actually, I'm here
about the assistant job.
- Really?
- So please don't fire me for doing this.
- I just think I'm passed the point
where I can, you know, just have fun.
- Rachel don't do this.
This is just because you're turning 30.
- Yeah, it is.
- Oh hi, I'm Mona, from her Restaurant.
- Oh.
Hello Mona from her restaurant.
- (gasp) Oh my god, you're Sputnik.
- Yes!
(audience laughing)
- Marry her.
- What?
- I love you.
(audience laughing)
(Mona cooing)
- And I love spending time with you.
- I'm pregnant.
- You know what, I can't
deal with this right now,
I'm sorry-
- Just think about it.
(baby crying)
- For the last time,
why aren't you two together again?
No, I know, I know,
because you're not in that place.
Which would be fine
except you totally are.
- It's complicated, okay?
Rachel said she'd marry you?
- This isn't the right room,
sorry folks. (audience laughing)
- You are the one who moved
on and didn't tell anyone.
- Oh my god, Ross, this
is just so messed up.
(sighs) What is wrong with us?
You know, when people
hear about our situation
they always ask, you live
together, but you're not a couple?
And you have a baby?
Isn't that weird?
And I say, you know, you know what?
It's not because it works for us.
But you know what, this doesn't work.
Kiss me.
- Rach, it doesn't say that.
- No I'm saying it.
- But, what-
- Just don't talk.
(audience cheering)
(Rachel gasping)
Well that's new.
- You like me?
- Okay, let's not make
a big thing about this.
- It's a huge thing.
- Okay, not working with me, Joe.
(audience laughing)
Here's the thing, lately I
have been having thoughts.
Musings, if you will.
(audience laughing)
- For how long?
- Only like a month.
- A month?
- You just went out with
my best friend, you know?
I just think it would be
a really really bad idea.
Or not.
(audience laughing)
(slow guitar music)
- Okay.
Ha ha, you like that, huh?
- Oh yeah.
- You like that.
Let's kick this into high gear, huh?
(Joey wincing)
Yeah baby, I'll show you how we do it.
- No, no, you kneed me in my misters.
- Well how come Monica
and Chandler could do it?
- I guess they weren't as
good friends as we are.
- I know I may be way out of bounds here,
but is there any chance
you would take me back?
- Oh god, I am so sorry,
but I mean,
there's so much history
between us, you know?
- The job is in Paris.
(gentle guitar music)
- I don't get a goodbye?
- What?
- Everyone gets a goodbye but me?
What do I gotta do to get a goodbye, huh?
Be best friends with you?
Go out with you?
Have a baby with you?
Oh wait a minute, wait a minute,
I did all those things.
- Okay, so if you think that
I didn't say goodbye to you
because you don't mean as
much to me as everybody else,
you're wrong.
It's because you mean more to me.
So there, all right, there's your goodbye.
- Rach!
- What?
- You can't!
- We totally did it.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my god, you and Rachel?
- I know, it's pretty great.
- So what does that mean?
Are you guys getting back together?
- Oh I don't know.
I mean we didn't really get to talk.
- It's just the perfect
way to say goodbye.
- I don't wanna get over her.
- What?
- I don't, I wanna be with her.
- Really?
- Yeah, I'm gonna go after her.
The thing is,
don't go.
- What?
- Please, please stay with me.
I am so in love with you.
Please don't go.
- Oh my god.
- I know, I know,
I shouldn't have waited til now to say it,
but that was stupid, okay, I'm sorry.
But I'm telling you now.
- I can't do this right now, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
- Rachel.
- I'm so sorry.
(answering machine beeping)
- [Rachel] Ross, hi.
It's me.
I just got back on the plane
and I just feel awful.
That is so not how I wanted
things to end with us.
It's just that I wasn't
expecting to see you
and then all of the sudden you're there
and saying these things and...
Now I'm just sitting here and thinking
of all the stuff I should
have said and I didn't.
I mean, I didn't even get to tell you
that I love you too.
Because of course I do.
I love you.
What am I doing?
(audience laughing)
I've gotta see you.
I've gotta get off this plane.
- Oh my god.
(audience laughing)
- [Rachel] Excuse me!
- [Stewardess] Miss, please, sit down.
(audience laughing)
- [Rachel] No sorry, but I
need to get off the plane,
okay, I need to just tell
someone that I love them.
- [Stewardess] Miss, I
can't let you off the plane.
- Let her off the plane!
(audience laughing)
- [Stewardess] I am
afraid you are gonna have
to take your seat.
- [Rachel] Oh please,
miss, you don't understand.
- Try to understand!
(audience laughing)
- [Rachel] Oh come on,
miss, isn't there any way
that you could just let me off the-
(beeping)
- No, no!
(laughing and gasping)
Oh my god, did she get off the plane?
Did she get off the plane?
- I got off the plane.
(audience cheering)
- You got off the plane.
- I do love you.
- I love you too and I'm
never letting you go again.
- Okay, 'cause this is
where I wanna be, okay?
No more messing around, I
don't wanna mess this up again.
- Me neither, okay?
We are done being stupid.
- Okay.
It's you and me, all right?
This is it.
- This is it.
Unless we're on a break.
(audience laughing)
Don't make jokes now.
(audience cheering)